the family of a Michigan man deported to
Mexico says that they will fight to get
him back to the US they blame a legal
blunder for his removal immigration
officials force Jorge Garcia to return
to Mexico this week
Garcia lived in the US for around 30
years he has an American wife and two
children our Warner is just back from
Michigan where she spoke with the family
and a lot of people talking about this
story good morning yeah good morning
Gail the Garcia family had been back and
forth with immigration officials since
the Obama administration so although
their concerns over deportation didn't
start with the Trump presidency the new
administration's change in its approach
to enforcement means those fears have
now become reality after 15 years of
marriage
Cindy Garcia had to say goodbye to her
husband her children had to part from
their father it was devastating we did
not want to let him go we said our
good-byes we told him we love you we're
gonna miss you but you don't want to let
somebody go that you love it's very hard
Garcia has lived in the US for some 30
years since a relative brought him here
from Mexico at the age of 10 he and
Cindy married in 2002 and began trying
to get him on the path to citizenship
through proper legal channels but she
says their first lawyer didn't follow
the right immigration procedures Diego
Bona Saudi is with Michigan United legal
services Jorge was exposed to ice
because of this application that should
not have been filed Garcia was ordered
removed but during the Obama
administration ice granted stays several
times while the couple worked to resolve
his residency issues then President
Trump came into office suddenly Garcia
was told he had to go ice told CBS News
in a statement that the agency exercised
prosecutorial discretion on multiple
prior occasions in Garcia's case but
that anyone violating immigration laws
may be subject to immigration arrest
detention and removal from the United
States I understand that the president
wants to protect our borders but at the
same time if
husband was brought in here as a child
he has no criminal record each
individual case needs to be looked at
because we tried to do the right thing
it's not like we didn't we try so what
do you say to people out there who say
well you know what he came to this
country illegally so tough look what I
like to tell them is he came at ten
years old so his somebody brought him
into the country so there was nothing
possibly that he could have done there
will be no ice coming to the door to try
to deport me because I am a US citizen
there's nothing ice can do to shut me up
well the Garcia family expects to be
apart from Jorge for at least 18 months
until they hope to get him an
appointment with a US consulate in
Mexico but delays in these cases often
go on for years and it's anyone's guess
actually whether he will ever be allowed
to return even to the US and live
legally in the US I hope it doesn't in
that way I also hope that people looking
at your story will now wanted people in
very important positions who can make
changes and do something to help him
because his wife said he didn't do
anything wrong they did all the right
things while he was in this country and
one of the things she wanted to say was
she's speaking out for the people who
can't speak out so because she's a
citizen no thanks